hacemos un problema un poco más
sofisticado de la ley de snl tenemos a
esta persona que se encuentra de pie al
borde de esta alberca esta persona tiene
un apuntador láser en su mano que está
con una elevación de 1.7 metros por
encima de este nivel de la piscina o de
la alberca enciende el apuntador y lo
apunta a una distancia de 8.1 metros
hacia el agua de la alberca y cuando el
aserto que el agua o la luz del láser
tocan el agua lo que va a tener es una
refracción quiero hablar el rayo hacia
adentro ya que cambia a un medio más
lento recordando la analogía del auto la
parte de la luz que tardé más en entrar
al medio más lento va a moverse más
rápido y ocasionará que se doble hacia
abajo esa luz va a tocar el fondo de la
alberca en este punto de acá la alberca
va a tener una profundidad de 3 metros
lo que quiero hacer es calcular qué tan
lejos es que llega este punto de luz con
respecto a este borde de la alberca
es decir quiero encontrar cuál es la
distancia de aquí a acá para calcular
esto primero tengo que encontrar cuál es
la distancia desde el borde de aquí de
la alberca hasta donde el rayo de luz
láser toca el agua es decir tengo que
encontrar la distancia
de aquí a acá y posteriormente encontrar
la distancia o la diferencia de
distancia de este punto de acá
este otro punto donde la luz del láser
dentro del agua toca la base de la
alberca y aplicando un poco de
trigonometría al igual que la ley de
snail lo vamos a poder resolver bueno
comencemos con la parte más simple
calculamos esta distancia de acá hasta
donde la luz toca el agua aquí aplicamos
directamente al teorema de pitágoras
vamos a llamar a esta distancia que nos
interesa encontrar la distancia x esta
distancia x aplicando el teorema tenemos
que x al cuadrado más este otro lado 1.7
al cuadrado va a ser igual a 8.1 al
cuadrado recordemos que el programa de
pitágoras nos dice que la suma del
cuadrado de ambos lados va a ser igual
al cuadrado de la hipotenusa para
el valor que nos interesa vamos a restar
en ambos lados de la ecuación 1.7 al
cuadrado por lo que nos va a quedar que
x al cuadrado es igual a 8.1 al cuadrado
menos 1.7 al cuadrado y si queremos
encontrar x pues va a ser la raíz
positiva de esta operación y es la raíz
positiva porque solo nos interesan las
distancias positivas x va a ser igual a
la raíz positiva de 8.1 al cuadrado
menos 1.7 al cuadrado sacamos nuestra
confiable calculadora y hacemos esta
operación vamos a obtener 8.1.1 al
cuadrado menos 1.7 al cuadrado y todo
esto
va a hacer famosa obtener la raíz
cuadrada que es 7.9 7.9 19 que vamos a
redondear lo aproximadamente a 7.92 así
que esta distancia es aproximadamente
igual a 7.92 metros y ese es el valor de
x
ahora queremos encontrar esta distancia
incremental de aquí abajo
agregarla a esta distancia que acabamos
de encontrar para poder encontrar la
distancia total que nos interesa
pensemos en cuáles son los ángulos de
incidencia y los ángulos de refracción
dibujamos aquí una perpendicular
a la superficie del agua y nuestro
ángulo de incidencia va a ser este
ángulo de acá
z 1 y recuerden que la ley de snl nos
interesa el seno del ángulo este ángulo
de aquí abajo va a ser nuestro ángulo de
refracción que éste está 2
vamos a escribir lo que sabemos bueno
sabemos que el índice de refracción de
aquí arriba del aire lo escribimos el
índice de refracción del aire en el aire
multiplicado por el seno de z 1 que es
nuestro ángulo de incidencia va a ser
igual esto es un 1 dólar va a ser igual
al índice de refracción del agua
el seno del ángulo de refracción que
esté todos sabemos que podemos conocer
el valor de estas en es de esta tabla y
si queremos encontrar a teta 2 o derecho
conociendo el seno detectados podemos
encontrar este lado de acá pues a
conocerte todos podemos aplicar algo de
trigonometría y encontrar este lado
ahora vamos a sustituir todos los
valores en esta fórmula el inicio de
refracción del aire aquí esta 1.000 29
11.000 29 por el seno detecta 1 y
ustedes me podrían decir bueno como
cálculo este seno si ni siquiera conozco
el ángulo pues recordemos que esto es de
trigonometría básica
recordemos nuestro neumónico
tohá
qué significa el seno es igual al lado
opuesto entre hipotenusa el cose no es
igual al lado adyacente entre la
hipotenusa y la tangente es igual al
lado opuesto entre el lado adyacente ese
no es el lado opuesto entre la
hipotenusa y si completamos aquí esto y
hacemos un triángulo invertido si este
nuestro ángulo recto pues el seno de
este ángulo va a ser este lado opuesto
entre la hipotenusa y ya tenemos estos
valores así que el seno de este ángulo
va a ser igual este seno va a ser igual
al valor que acabamos de encontrar para
x que es
7.92 entre el valor de la hipotenusa que
es de 8.1 esto es el seno del ángulo
theta 1 y esto va a ser igual al índice
de refracción del agua que es 1.33 1.33
por el seno del ángulo 2 que esto es
lo que nos interesa seno del ángulo 2
para despejar esto vamos a dividir ambos
lados de la ecuación entre 1.33 por lo
que vamos a tener aquí esto entre 1.33
aquí también esto entre 1.33 nos va a
quedar entonces el seno
dt todos es igual
1.000 29 / 1.33
7.92 / 8.1 y para resolver esto sacamos
nuestra confiable calculadora y vamos a
dividir esta cantidad entre 8.1 y esto
lo vamos a multiplicar multiplicar por
1.000 29 entre un 1.33 cerramos
paréntesis y el resultado es 0.73 53 que
vamos a redondear lo apunto 735
esto es igual el seno
detectados es igual a cero puntos
setecientos
a 35 y como queremos obtener este ángulo
detectados vamos a obtener el seno
inverso en ambos lados de esta ecuación
nos quedará entonces beta 2 es igual al
seno inverso
de punto 7 35 obtenemos esta operación
de nuevo sacamos nuestra calculadora con
el resultado que acabamos de obtener y
esto le aplicamos el seno inverso y nos
queda que como estamos en grados esta
operación está bien 47 puntos 33
6 grados
qué podemos redondear a 47 punto 34
grados entonces lo escribimos por acá de
todos es igual a 47 puntos 34 grados
bien ya pudimos encontrar el valor de
teta 2 sólo nos queda usar algo de
trigonometría para encontrar la
distancia que nos interesa de aquí abajo
vamos a hacer un poquito de espacio cuál
función trigonométricas tenemos que usar
aquí bueno queremos conocer el lado
opuesto de este ángulo theta 2 y
conocemos el lado adyacente este valor
de acá de 3 metros pues la función
trigonométricas que nos sirve es la
tangente tangente es igual a opuesto
entre adyacente vamos a tener que la
tangente de este ángulo que encontramos
47.34 va a ser igual a esta distancia
del lado opuesto que es la que nos
interesa y que voy a llamar
va a ser igual a james entre este el
cateto adyacente que es de 3 metros
si queremos despejar llevamos a
multiplicar ambos lados de esta ecuación
por 3 y nos va a quedar 3 por tangente
de 47.34 grados va a ser igual a jr
calculadora nuevamente tenemos aquí el
ángulo a éste lo obtenemos la tangente y
la tangente la multiplicamos por 3 nos
queda 3.25 5 metros entonces va a ser
igual a 3.25 5 metros nuestra pregunta
original era cuál es la distancia de
este borde hasta el punto en donde se
refleja la luz del rayo láser en la base
de la alberca para obtener esta
distancia sumamos este valor de x más
este valor de ella x quedamos que era
7.92 metros y a esto le vamos a sumar
3.25 5 metros sacamos nuevamente nuestra
calculadora a esta cantidad que acabamos
de encontrar le sumamos
7.92 7.92 y el resultado es de 11.10 y
75 podemos hacer 11 puntos 18 metros la
distancia esta distancia
es aproximadamente igual aproximadamente
igual a 11.18 metros de aquí del borde
hasta donde se refleja el rayo de luz en
la base este foto a problema de la ley
de snl en la que lo más difícil fue
aplicar la trigonometría en donde la
clave era encontrar el ángulo theta 1 y
obtener su seno y de ahí lo usamos junto
con la ley de snl para encontrar este
otro ángulo teta 2 y finalmente usamos
este y más trigonometría para encontrar
el lado que nos interesaba y hacer la
suma para encontrar el total